what do you think about Vladimir Putin
the man and the leader
let's actually look at the full you've
written a lot about him the the recent
Vladimir Putin and the the full context
of his life
um let's zoom out and look at the last
20 plus years of his rule
in what ways has he been good for Russia
in what way is bad
well if you look to the first couple of
terms
of his presidency I think you know on
the uh overall Ledger you would have
actually said that he
made a lot of achievements from Russia
now there was of course the pretty
black period of the war in chechnya but
you know he didn't start that that was
Boris Yeltsin that was obviously a
pretty catastrophic uh event but if you
look at then other parts of the ledge of
what Putin was doing you know from the
2000s you know onwards he stabilized the
Russian economy uh brought back you know
kind of confidence uh and and the
Russian economy and financial system
he built up a pretty impressive team of
technocrats rather than the central bank
and the economics and you know Finance
Ministries
um who um you know really got the
country back into ship again and solvent
paid off all of the debts and you know
really started to
um build the country back up again
domestically
and you know the first couple of terms
again putting chechnya you know to one
side which is a little hard because I
mean there was a lot of atrocities and I
have to say that you know he was pretty
involved in all of that because the FSB
which he'd headed previously you know
was in charge of wrapping up chechnya
and it created you know kind of a of a
very strange sort of system of fealty
almost a feudal system in the kind of
relationship between uh Putin at the top
and kadira Frances now there was quite a
lot of distortions you know kind of as a
result of that in the way that the
Russian Federation was run you know a
lot more of an emphasis on the security
services for example but there was a lot
of pragmatism you know opening up the
country for business
um you know basically extending
relationships I would say that you know
by the end of those first couple of
terms of uh Putin Russians were living
their best lives
um you know there was a lot of
opportunity for people uh people the
labor you know was being paid for they
weren't being taxed the taxes were
coming out of the extractive industries
uh there was you know kind of a I guess
a sense of much more political pluralism
um but it wasn't the kind of the chaos
of the Elton period
and then you see a shift
and it's pretty much when he comes back
into Power again
in 2011 2012.
and that's when we see a kind of a
different phase emerging
and you know part of it is the the
larger International environment where
Putin is himself has become kind of
convinced of the United States is up to
to get him and part of it goes back to
the decision on the part of the United
States from invade Iraq in 2003
there's also you know the recognition of
Kosovo in 2008 and you know the whole
kind of machinations around all kinds of
you know other issues of NATO expansion
and elsewhere but Iraq in 2003 and this
kind of whole idea after that that the
United States is in the business of
regime change and perhaps you know has
him in his crosshairs as well
but there's also then kind of I think a
sense of building crisis after the
financial crisis and the Great Recession
2008 2009 because I think Putin up until
then believed in you know the whole idea
of the Global Financial system and that
Russia was prospering and that Russia
you know part of the G8 actually could
be genuinely one of the you know the
major economic and financial powers
and then suddenly he realizes that in
the west is incompetent that you know we
totally mismanage the economy of our own
the financial crash in the United States
the kind of blowing up of the uh of the
the housing bubble and that we were
feckless
and that we that had global
reverberations
and he's prime minister of course you
know in this kind of period but then you
know and I think that that kind of
compels him to kind of come back into
the presidency and try to kind of uh
take things under control again in
2007-2012 and after that he goes into
kind of a much more sort of focused role
where he sees the United States as a big
bigger problem
and he also
you know starts to you know kind of
focus on also uh the domestic uh
environment because his return to the
presidency is met by protests and he
genuinely seems to believe because again
this is very similar to belief here in
the United States that Donald Trump
couldn't possibly related by Americans
there somehow was some kind of external
inter interference because the Russians
interfered and had an impact Putin
himself thinks at that time it's one of
the reasons why he interferes in our
elections later that the United States
and others had interfere because he knew
that people weren't that thrilled about
him coming back it kind of like the
Medvedev period
and the protests and Moscow and Saint
Petersburg and other major cities he
starts to believe we're instigated by
the west by the outside
because of you know funding for
um transparency in elections and you
know all of the
um ngos and others you know they're
operating State departments Embassy
funding you know the and the you know
the whole attitude of God is back you
know kind of thing
and so after that we see Putin going on
a very different footing it's also
somewhere in that period
2011-2012 we start to kind of obsess
about Ukraine
and he's always you know I think being
kind of steeped in that whole view of
Russian history I mean I heard at that
time I was in I've written about this
and many of the things that you know
I've written about Putin that in that
same time frame I'm going to all these
conferences in Russia where Putin is and
peskov has uh press secretary and they
talk about him reading Russian history I
think is this in this kind of poo that
he formulates this idea
of
the necessity
of reconstituting the Russian World the
Russian Empire he's obviously been very
interested in this he's always said of
course at the collapse of the Soviet
Union was the great catastrophe of 20th
century but also the collapse of the
Russian Empire before it and he starts
to be critical about lending the
Bolsheviks and he starts to do all this
talking about Ukraine
as
the same country ukrainians and Russians
being one and the same and this is where
the Ledger flips because I mean the
initial question you asked me is about
has Russia has Putin been good for
Russia or not and this is where we get
into the uh focal point of uh or the
point where he's not focusing on the
prosperity instability and future of
Russia but he starts to obsess about the
past
and you start to take things in a very
different direction he starts to clamp
down at home because of the rise of
opposition and the fact that he knows
that his you know brand is not the same
as it was before his popularity is not
the same as it was before because he's
already gone over that you know that
period in
anybody's you know professional and you
know political life that you know if you
stay around long enough people get a bit
sick of you you know just be talked
about that before should you stay you
know kind of in any job for a long
period of time you need refreshing and
you know kind of Putin is you know
starting to look like he's going to be
there forever and people are not happy
about that
and would like the chance as well to
kind of move on and move up and you know
with him and still in place that's not
going to be uh particularly possible and
that you know it's around the time when
he starts to make that decision and
annexing Crimea and that's when the
whole thing flips in my view the
annexation of Crimea in 2014 is the
beginning of the end
I've been a Vladimir Putin being a
positive force within Russia because if
you
pay very close attention
to his speech on the annexation of
Crimea
in March of 2014 you see all the
foreshadowing of you know where we are
now it's already of kind of his view of
kind of his obsessions his historical
Obsession his view of himself has been
kind of fused with the state of kind of
a modern Czar and his idea that the West
is up to get him and it becomes after
that almost a kind of like a Messianic
Mission you know to turn things in a
different direction